so let's say that we have y is equal to
the secant of 3 PI over 2 minus X and
what we want to do is we want to figure
out what dy/dx is the derivative of Y
with respect to X is at X equal PI over
4 like always pause this video and see
if you could figure it out well as you
can see here we have a composite
function we're taking the secant not
just of X but you could view this as of
another expression that I guess you
could define or is of another function
so for example if we call this right
over here U of X so let's do that so if
we say U of X is equal to 3 PI over 2
minus X and we could also figure out u
prime of X is going to be equal to
derivative of 3 PI over 2 that's just
going to be 0 derivative of minus X well
that's just going to be minus 1 and you
could just view that as a power rule
it's 1 times negative 1 times X to the 0
power which is just 1 so there you go so
we could view this as the derivative of
secant with respect to U of X and when
we take the derivative the derivative of
secant with respect to U of x times the
derivative of U with respect to X and
you might say well what about the
derivative of secant well in other
videos we actually prove it out and you
could actually read arrive it secant is
just 1 over cosine of X so it comes
straight out of the chain rule so in
other videos we proved that the the
derivative of the secant of X of secant
of X is equal to is equal to sine of X
over cosine of X over cosine of x
squared so if we're trying to find the
derivative of Y with respect to X well
it's going to be the derivative of
secant with respect to U of x times the
derivative of U with respect to X so
let's do that the derivative of secant
with respect to U of X well instead of
seeing an X everywhere you're going to
see a U of X every
so this is going to be sine of U of X
sine of U of X and I could I don't have
to write U of X I could write 3 PI over
2 minus X but I'll write U of X right
over here just to really visualize what
we're doing so sine of U of x over over
cosine squared of U of X cosine squared
let me do those parentheses in the blue
color just to make sure that you
identify it with a trig function so
cosine squared of U of X U of X so
that's the derivative of secant with
respect to U of X and then the chain
rule tells it's going to be that times u
prime u prime of X so what is this going
to be equal to well I could just
substitute back this is going to be
equal to I will write it like this sine
of U of X which is 3 PI over 2 minus X
and I'll fill that in a second over
cosine of U of x squared times u prime
of X U of X is 3 PI over 2 minus X 3 PI
over 2 minus X and then u prime of X we
all we already figured out is negative 1
so I could write x negative 1 oh yeah
let me just leave it out there for now I
could I could have just put a negative
out front but I really want you to be
able to see what I'm doing here and now
we want to evaluate at x equals PI over
4 so when that is equal to PI over 4 PI
over 4 so let's see this is going to be
this is going to be equal to sine of
what's 3 PI over 2 minus PI over 4 I'll
do that over here so if you have a
common denominator that is 6 PI over 4
that's the same thing as 3 PI over 2
minus PI over 4 sorry minus PI over 4 is
equal to 5 5 PI over 4 so it's sine of 5
PI over 4
five PI over four over cosine squared of
five PI over four and then times
negative one I could just put that out
here now what is sine of five PI over
four and cosine squared of five PI over
four
well I don't have that memorized but
let's actually draw a unit circle and we
should be able to we should be able to
figure out what that is
so a unit circle I try to hand draw it
as best as I can please forgive me that
this circle does not look really like a
circle all right okay so let me just
remember my angles so I in my brain I
sometimes convert into degrees PI over
four is 45 degrees this is PI over 2
this is 3 PI over 4 this is 4 PI over 4
this is 5 PI over 4 lens you right over
there
so if if you wanted to see where the you
intersect the unit circle this is at the
point this is at the point your
x-coordinate is negative square root of
2 over 2
negative square root of 2 over 2 and
your y-coordinate is negative square
root of 2 over 2 if you're wondering how
I got that I encourage you to review the
unit circle and some of the standard
angles around the unit circle you'll see
that in the trigonometry section of Khan
Academy but this is enough for us
because the sine is the y-coordinate
it's the y-coordinate here so negative
square root of 2 over 2 so this is
negative square root of 2 over 2 and
then the cosine is the x-coordinate
which is also negative square root of 2
over 2 what's going to be that squared
negative square root of 2 over 2 we're
squaring it so if we square this it's
going to be calm this is going to become
it's going to become positive and then
square root of 2 squared is 2 and then 2
squared is 4 so it's 1/2 so this is the
denominator is equal to 1/2 C in the
numerator this negative cancels that
with
that negative and so we are left with we
deserve a little bit of a drumroll that
we are left with square root of two over
two that's the numerator divided by
one-half well that's the same thing as
multiplying by two so we are left with
positive square root of two is the slope
of the tangent line to the graph of y is
equal to this when X is equal to PI over
four pretty exciting